le bras de fer diplomatique entre la
chine et les etats unis se durcit et
c'est face à la presse depuis la maison
blanche que donald trump annonce sa
dernière mesures fortes contre pékin la
fin du traitement économiques
préférentielles accordées à hong kong
aujourd'hui j'ai signé un décret mettant
fin au traitement préférentiel accordé
par les états unis hong kong hong kong
sera traitée comme la chine
pas de privilège spécial pas de
traitement économique spéciale est pas
d'exportation de technologies sensibles
en plus de cela comme vous le savez nous
mettons en place des taxes importantes
et avons mis en place des taxes très
importante sur la chine c'est la
première fois que ça arrive à la chine
cette décision de donald trump fait
suite à l'instauration par la chine
d'une loi draconienne sur la sécurité
nationale dans le territoire semi
autonome depuis plus d'un an les
manifestations parfois gigantesques se
multiplient contre le pouvoir chinois
pour le président américain pékin ne
cherche qu'à remettre en cause le
caractère semi autonome de hong kong
nous avons tous observé ce qui s'est
produit la situation n'est pas bonne
leur liberté leur a été retiré leurs
droits alors ont été retirés avec hong
kong disparaît à mon avis parce qu'il ne
sera plus capable d'être compétitif dans
un marché libre beaucoup de gens vont
partir de hong kong c'est ce que je
soupçonne et nous allons faire beaucoup
plus d'affaires grâce à ça nous avons
perdu un concurrent très très sérieux
avec cette décision le président
américain souhaite porter un coup majeur
à la puissance économique de l'ex
colonie britannique
et cette annonce s'ajoute à d'autres
sanctions le congrès américain a voté
début juillet une loi permettant de
sanctionner des responsables qui
seraient identifiés comme ouvrant pour
restreindre les libertés à hong kong
de son côté le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mike pompéo a félicité les
parties opposées à pékin qui ont
organisé des primaires dans l'optique
des législatives de septembre prochain
sur un autre plan les états unis ont
aussi annoncé qu'ils refuseraient des
visas à trois hauts responsables chinois
accusés d'être impliqués dans la
répression contre les ouïghours
dans ce contexte et sans surprise
la chine a déjà annoncé des représailles
contre des intérêts économiques
américains